[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض في الذكرى العشرين للعربيه يوم
استثنائي بالفعل خالد نبدا هذه النشره
بالعناوين
صراعه بخموت يشتد رئيس فاجنر يقول ان
المدينه محاصره ويدعو قوات كييف للاستسلام
تسيير الحزن الثاني من المساعدات السعوديه
لاوكرانيا ثلاث طائرات تحمل مولدات
كهربائيه ومواد اغاثيه
في الرابعه ايضا
مكافحه المخدرات في السعوديه مستمره ضبط
اكثر من سبعه ملايين حبه مخدره خلال اقل
من 24 ساعه
من العلا على الهواء مباشره
والعربيه تحتفي بالذكرى العشرين شاهده لا
تغيب عن توثيق الاحداث عربيه كانت او
عالميه
اهلا بكم يوم استثنائي ونسخه استثنائي من
الرابعه في الذكرى العشرين لتاسيس قناه
العربيه وقبل البدء في تغطيه الخاصه نبدا
بمعتدتم عليه من العربيه طوال عقدين اخر
الاخبار والتطورات من حول العالم الخبر
اولا وثانيا ودائما لنعرف وتعرف اكثر
وجه رئيس مجموعه الروسيه يافقيني
خطابا الى الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير في
مقطع فيديو مصور نشره على قناه في
تيليجرام طلب فيه بالانسحاب من وادي من
مدينه باغموت مؤكدا ان المدينه محاصره
بالكامل
انني اخاطب رئيس اوكرانيا
لقد حاصرت وحدات فاجنر العسكريه بخموت
عمليا لم يتبقى سوى طريق واحد مفتوح امام
القوات الاوكرانيه الكماشه تزداد احكاما
انهم يقاتلون لكن حياتهم في بخموت في خطر
دعهم يغادرون المدينه لانها محاطه عمليا
حضرت روسيا من ان ارسال شحنات اسلحه غربيه
جديده الى كييف سيطيل الصراع وسيكون له
عواقب وخيمه على الشعب الاوكراني وذلك قبل
لقاء في واشنطن بين الرئيس الامريكي
والمستشار الالماني وقال المتحدث باسم
الكرم شحنات الاسلحه تضع اعبئا كبيرا على
اقتصادات هذه الدول وتؤثر سلبا على رفاهيه
مواطنيها بما في ذلك المانيا
من كيف ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا حذيفه ضعنا في اخر التطورات
خالد وفاطمه كل عام وانتم بخير والعربيه
والمشاهدها بالف خير في الحقيقه الوضع في
باخمه يعني في
وضع صعب جدا كما افاده القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الضغط كبير جدا من قوات فاجنر
الروسيه من جميع من الجهات الثلاث من
الجهه الشرقيه ومن الجهه الشماليه ومن
الجهه الجنوبيه خاصه الجهه الشماليه هنالك
عمليات اقتحام مستمره تحاول ان تقوم بها
القوات الروسيه ولكن ما زالت القوات
الاوكرانيه والجيش الاوكراني يؤكد انه ما
زال يسيطر على المدينه وعلى مركز المدينه
وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تدخل قوات فاجنر الى
داخل المدينه ولكنها طبعا في تخوم المدينه
ايضا المركز المقاومه الوطني الاوكراني
نشر حول ما تم تداوله من قبل وهو قائد
الانفصاليين في الذي قال انه يصور هذا
الفيديو الذي تحدث عن انه داخل المدينه
قالوا ان هذا الفيديو بعد التحليل هو مق
القرائد فان هذا الفيديو تم تصويره في وهي
قريه شماليه ضخمه وليس في مدينه باكموت
نفسها وان هذا الفيديو الهدف منه طبعا
ترويع المواطنين الاوكرانيين وبث الذعر
وتضليل المواطنين والجيش كذلك وايضا تشويه
سمعه القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه هذا من
جانب ايضا وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
تحدث عن الخسائر التي تتكبدها القوات
الروسيه في مدينه باقود قال انهم يخسرون
في اليوم على اقل تقدير 500 جندي وهم
يحاولون منذ سته اشهر ولكنهم لا يجدون اي
نجاح في هذه الجبهه وما زلنا نسيطر على
المدينه وهنالك ما زال امكانيه لايصال
الامدادات طبعا ايضا شبكه سي ان ان كانت
قد اجرت بعض الاستطلاعات وبعض المقابلات
مع الشرطه الوطنيه في ادونيسكو التي افادت
من خلالها عن ان المنطقه اصبحت يعني ان
الروس قاموا بتدمير الجسر الذي يربط شاص
نابيار بباكموت وهو الطريقه الوحيد الذي
يمكن من خلاله ايصال الامدادات وكذلك
عمليه الاجلاء للمدنيين ايضا افادت بان
هنالك حوالي 5000 مواطن ما زالوا داخل
المدينه بينهم 37 طفلا ولا يستطيعون
الخروج الا من خلال هذا الجسر الشرطه
الوطنيه تقول انها ان هنالك اعمال صيانه
جاريه لهذا الجسر ولكن هنالك طرق بديله
ترابيه يمكن من خلالها ايصال الامدادات
وكذلك الخروج لذلك حتى اللحظه تؤكد
السلطات الاوكرانيه انها ما زالت تسيطر
على مدينه شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسل العربيه حذيفه
نبقى في تطورات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
حيث اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسي روسيا لن
تسمح للغرب بتفجير انابيب الغاز مره اخرى
واضاف وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان بلاده لن
تعتمد بعد الان على الشركاء الغربيين في
مجال الطاقه مضيفا انها ستعتمد على شركاء
موثوق بهم في سياسه الطاقه بما في ذلك
الصين والهند
وقال سياسه الطاقه في روسيا ستكون موجهه
نحو الشركاء موثوق بهم في اشاره الى الهند
والصين مشيرا في نفس الوقت لان بلاده لن
تسمح مره اخرى للغرب لتفجير انابيب الغاز
العابره للبحار
الحرب التي نحاول وقفها والتي شن ضدنا
باستخدام اشخاص اوكرانيين اثرت بالطبع على
سياسه روسيا بما في ذلك السياسه الطاقه
بعد الان لن نعتمد على الغرب بسياسه
الطاقه الروسيه ولنسمح لهم بتفجير انابيب
الغاز العابره للبحار مره اخرى
نائب مجلس الامن الروسي قال ان تسليم
النيت طائرات الى اوكرانيا وصيانتها في
بولندا سيكون دخولا مباشرا الى الحرب في
الحرب ضد روسيا واكد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
انه سيتعين اعتبار كل من يقرر توريد او
صيانه هذه المعدات او وسائل التدمير الى
جانب المرتزقه الاجانب والمدربين
العسكريين هدفا عسكريا مشروعا على حد وصفه
انسانيا بدات السعوديه تسيير الحزمه
الثانيه من الجسر الجوي لمساعدتها او
مساعداتها الى اوكرانيا تحتوي هذه الحزمه
على مولدات للطاقه الكهربائيه اضافه الى
مواد اغاثيه وايوائيه عبر ثلاث طائرات
هذه هي الحزمه الثانيه من المساعدات
السعوديه المقدمه الى جمهوريه اوكرانيا
والبلق قيمتها 400 مليون دولار هذه الحزمه
تحتوي على مولدات للطاقه الكهربائيه وموده
غذائيه وايوائيه
ستسيرها السعوديه عبر جسر جوي في مرحلته
الاولى بثلاث طائرات تغادر من مطار الملك
خالد الدولي في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
الى مطار جيشوف في بولندا ثم بعد ذلك تنقل
المساعدات بواسطه شاحنات نقل الى داخل
اوكرانيا
في هذا الجانب تقف الطائره الاولى من
الجسر الجوي السعودي حيث ستحمل اكثر من 80
طن من هذه المساعدات هنا نواكب عمليه نقل
المساعدات من ساحه ارض المطار الى داخل
الطائره الاولى
لقناتي العربيه والحدث هاني الصفيان
الرياض
على هامشى منتدى حوار رايسينا في الهند
التقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
ابن فرحان بوزير الخارجيه الهندي صبرا
هامانيام جيشانكر وبحث الجانبان تعزيز
التنسيق الثنائي في القضايا الاقليميه
والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك كما التقى
الامير فيصل بن فرحان نظيره البرازيلي
معروف وجرى خلال اللقاء استعراض العلاقات
المشتركه وبحث سبل تعزيز التعاون
الاقتصادي والتنموي المشترك
في اخبارنا المتنوعه في الرابعه منحت
جامعه الملك عبد الله للعلوم والتقنيه
كاوست عبر مبادره التقدم تمويلا بقيمه
مليون دولار امريكي الى 10 شركات ناشئه
بهدف دعم رياده الاعمال والتقنيه المبتكره
هذا وعملت الجامعه خلال العشر سنوات
الاخيره عبر برامجها على تخريج نحو 346
شركه ناشئه تركز على معالجه قضايا منها
استدامه الغذاء والمياه
في جمع اكثر من 300 مليون دولار من
التمويل الاستثماري لدعم هذه الشركات يذكر
او يذكر مبادرات رياده الاعمال اسهمت برفع
قيمه الاستثمارات في قطاع الشركات الناشئه
في العام الماضي الى نحو 72% في السعوديه
احبطت الجمارك السعوديه في منفذ الحديث
محاوله التهريب نحو مليوني حبه كبتاجون
عثر عليها مخبا في ارساليه طماطم ورمان
محموله على احدى الشاحنات القادمه الى
المنفذ
كما احبطت ايضا وزاره الداخليه السعوديه
يوم امس نحو خمسه ملايين قرص من ماده
فيتامين المخدر وجدت في داخل شحنه من
كابلات في العاصمه الرياض جرى من خلالها
ضبط مستقبلها وهو او مستقبلها وهو مقيم
لنظام امن الحدود من الجنسيه السوريه اتخذ
بحقه الاجراءات النظاميه واحيل الى
النيابه العامه
رابع مستمر فيها بعد قليل
العربيه تختفي بالذكرى العشرين شاهده لا
تغيب عن توثيق الاحداث عربيه عالميه
[موسيقى]
تاثير القناه تجلى في قدراتها على النشر
الوعي والثقافه في المجتمعات العربيه من
كل موظفي وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه نشكركم
على استضافاتنا على مدار العشرين عامل
الماضيه ونتمنى لكم دوام نتقدم والابداع
والنجاح ونتطلع الى المزيد من التعاون الف
الف مبروك
[موسيقى]
عشرون عاما مضت والعربيه في صداره المشهد
السعودي عبر شبكه مراسليها الذين يتابعون
اولا باول كيف تصدت السلطات السعوديه في
حرب شرسه لتنظيم القاعده حتى القضاء عليه
هذا وجه من اوجه تغطيه العربيه للشان
السعودي ولنا في نشره الرابعه تحديدا
سنوات وذكريات لا تحصى مع مشاهدينا نتابع
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه في رياض ان سته اشخاص
من بينهم امريكي وفليبيني قتلوا في اطلاق
نار في ضحيه الراكه بمنطقه الخبر الشرقيه
السعوديه
تضرب طوقنا امنيا على هذا المجمع
وثلاثه فلبينيين قتلوا في الهجوم
فمن الواضح انه مخطئ عمر الزبيدي العربيه
مدينه الخبر
قال بيان لوزاره الداخليه السعوديه ان
العمليه الامنيه التي جرت في المدينه
المنوره اسفرت عن مقتل اثنين من المطلوبين
منهم صالح الاوفي القيادي والبرز في تنظيم
القاعده في السعوديه في منتصف عقد
التسعينيات من القرن الماضي نشط العوفي في
الاراضي الافغانيه الى جانب ابي معاذ
الخسقيل وزاره الداخليه في الفتره الماضيه
كشف عن وجود بعض الخلايا المختبعه داخل
احياء السكنيه
ثلاث قوات الامن السعوديه القاء القبض على
خمسه مسلحين على صله بالهجوم الانتحاريه
على اكبر منشاه في العالم لتكرير النفط في
بقيق في هذا الشريط ظهرت صور المنافدين
الخمسه الذين قتلت اثنين منهم في عمليه
[موسيقى]
هذه الخليه هي تمثل تنظيم القاعده منذ
بدايه نشاطه في المملكه
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه لو تيجي الناحيه شويه
يقال بان
يقال ان ما انت مركز مفاسد
كيف واجهت السعوديه القاعده كان بيان لدول
الخليج الاستجابه لطلب الرئيس اليمني بردع
ميليشيا الحوثي وتنظيمي القاعده وداعش على
البلاد الهدف هو ايجاد معادله توازن في
خبر عاجل ورد قبل قليل القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه تقصف مواقع
للانقلابيين الحوثيين في اليمن المساله
وصلت الى حدها الاقصى
[موسيقى]
عمليه عاصفه الحزم وقال البيان ان عمليه
جديده اطلق عليها اعاده الامل
[موسيقى]
من الرياض الى متابعيها في السعوديه
والخليج والعالم تنطلق اليوم من غرفه
اخبار العربيه نشره الرابعه ضمن نشرات
الاخبار من العاصمه السعوديه نبدا بابرز
العناوين قناه العربيات تفتح مقرها في
العاصمه الرياض وتبدا عمليات البث بتقنيات
متقدمه
[موسيقى]
فيديوهاتنا في رياض الكاتب الصحفي جاسر
الجاسر سجل جاسر حياك الله معي نبارك
لانفسنا ونبارك لك ايضا وصول العربيه الى
العشرين اليوم هذه مناسبه يعني مميزه
ولافته لانه مو فقط للعربيه للاعلام
العربي ككل يعني في جانب دائما مشكله
الاعلام العربي كان
غلبه النبره الخطابيه واحيانا تشنج
الهيدروجي العربيه حتى حتى انتم من
المذيعين ما اشعر انا بحاله هدائيه معكم
ابو عبد الله مش خطابيين يعني فترتاح
تتلقى الخبر بتلقائيه وعفويه في وضع
الطبيعي ولا تحس ان المذيع يدفعك الى موقف
معين او يلزمك باتجاه معين او يحاول اني
اشحن المشاهد
ما تعبناك يعني كثير في التغطيات
والمناسبات
غير ايدولوجيين
كانت المشكله كبيره حياك الله
ايضا من دبي
العتيبي الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك معنا من
دبي استاذ عبد الله حياك الله معنا في
الذكرى العشرين لنجاح العربيه في تغطيه
الاحداث حول العالم حياك الله
اهلا وسهلا ومبروكين جميعا
عقدين من الزمن من نجاح العربيه اللي
صراحه شكلت فارق في التاريخ الاعلام
والاعلام السياسي العربي بشكل عام شكرا لك
استاذ عبد الله العلي ابدا معك ساد جاسر
بما انك معانا في الاستوديو هنا بالرياض
يعني منذ 2003 العالم مر باحداث وظروف
ومواقف سياسيه ربما غيرت ايضا المشهد من
حول العالم كيف المسار او ما المسار الذي
اختارته العربيه في تغطياتها وانا اتحدث
على الصعيد الاقليمي والصعيد العالم يعني
عندنا غزو العراق عندنا احداث 11 سبتمبر
وحتى الربيع العربي
لو ما كانت في مثل العربيه في تلك الفتره
يعني ما كان في صوت لنقل اقليمي كانت
المحطات يعني الاحتضار موجوده كما ذكرت
قبله هيدروجيه محليه بحته فبالتالي ما كان
هناك خطاب كان في تحديات كثيره المشاهد
العربي بالدرجه الاولى لم يكن لديه منصه
تستطيع ان توصله للا احداثه ما يحدث
تستطيع ان تنقله من الزاويه الضيقه الخاصه
بتلك الجهه او الايدولوجيا المعينه الى
دائره الحدث الى التوازن فبالتالي لما
ظهرت العربيه اذا كانت في فتره حرج جدا
وكانت ابرز سمات تلك الفتره طبعا
مساله غزو العراق كان ايضا الارهاب يعني
يضرب في مناطق كثيره في العالم العربي
وخصوصا في السعوديه والخليج الكبير اللي
واجهته مع القاعده وغيرها مهم جدا في
عمليه انه في تلك الفتره ما كان في صوت
يعني كانت العربيه تقوم بهذا الدور بشكل
كبير
وتحليليا والموقف والجانب الاخر انها تعزز
يعني قناه تتبنى مواقف لنقل اخلاقيه معينه
في سياق تحقيق الاستقرار الدعم المعلومه
وليست المعلومه بمعنى التحريضي كما يحدث
احيانا او بمعنى الموقف يسهم في نقل
معلومه بدون مساس او بما يشجع الاستقراره
والطمانينه وبمشكل ايضا موقفا ضد العمليات
خاصه مثلا في الارهاب في تلك الفتره او
النقل المجسد والصريح للحدث
بموضوعيه احنا ما نقول حياديه للاعلام ما
في حياديه لكن موضوعيه حضور في الميدان
نبره متوازنه في الخطاب منح الاطراف
الاصوات المختلفه الكامله وبالتالي تصل
للمشاهد او المتابع الصوره كامله مجسده
بدون زوايا مظلمه وبدون مسارات مجبر عليها
او مسارات الزمنيه
في العربيه خالد يعني الموضوعيه بشكل كبير
كامل والحكم طبعا للمشاهد دائما وابدا هنا
اذهب اليك استاذ عبد الله صديقي العزيز
الذي يرافقنا دائما في التغطيات في
الحوارات في التعليقات استاذ عبد الله بن
بجاد ضيفي من دبي حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
اللي ذكرها الاستاذ جاسر مساله الارهاب
والتطرف تعلم بانه هذه الظاهره اجتاحت
معظم مناطق العالم وان كانت بدرجات
متفاوته وعانت منطقه الشرق الاوسط كثيرا
من هذه والخليج والسعوديه تحديدا
اريد ان اقف معك استاذ عبدالله على ابرز
المحطات والذكريات بالنسبه لعبد الله بن
جاد في نظرته الى تعاطي العربيه ومقاربتها
في طريقتها وتعاملها لمواجهه ظاهره غيرها
نعم هذا الحقيقه التاريخ مشرف لكن دعني
مدخل بسيط الاعلام العربي مثل ما ذكر
الاستاذ جاسر قبل قليل هو اعلام بدا
تعبويا وادرجا على مدى عقود من الزمن في
بدايه التسعينات مع خروج الام بي سي كانت
نشرات اخبار متفرقه ضمن الترفيه تحاول ان
تعرض بشكل محايد ثم في منتصف التسعينات
عندما كانت القناه الاخباريه الاولى
المؤدلجه بشكل كامل التي تبحث عن الراي
وتبحث عن التعبئه وتبحث عن الحشد وتبحث عن
هذا الخط وهذا المسار اثار الكثير من
المشكلات لدى المشاهد العربي وفي الوعي
العربي لما خرجت العربيه في 2003 كان
الرهان هو على المعلومه على الخبر بدون
تدخل للراي بدون تدخل سافر للاديولوجيا
بدون
حشد للمشاهدين بعد ذلك 2003 كانت
الحرب العراق ثم
الانتقال القاعده الى داخل السعوديه
والحرب الشرسه لخيضه ضد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فكانت العربيه مواكبه لهذه
الاحداث بنفس القيمه الخبر والمعلومه
والتحليل الصائب الذي يعرض للمشاهد
ليتابعه ويصنعه هو بنفسه رايه فغطت
العربيه هذه الاحداث عن الارهاب بشكل
موضوعي وبشكل دقيق وخرج ايضا برنامج يمكن
لاجل علاقتي الشخصيه برنامج صناعه الموت
كاول برنامج على مستوى العالم مخصص
بالكامل لتناول موضوع الارهاب مفاهيم
وجذور وحركات وتنظيمات ورموز وعرض كل هذا
للمشاهد باسلوب
اخباري تلفزيوني يستطيع ان يفكك مثل هذه
الظاهره
يحللها ويقدم راي مستمر فيها ولله الحمد
بحكم قوه القناه وحكم وقوه التوجه في في
التناول سجل البرنامج ارقام كبيره في
المشاهده على فترات معينه
واستمر في هذا النجاح حتى ادى دوره ولم
يقف دور العربيه العربيه مستمره في تغطيه
كافه الامور بما فيها مساله الارهاب وما
يتعلق بالارهاب
يمكن
ربيع العربي من اهم كان القضايا المثيره
للجدل في مساله التعاطي الاعلام لما
رافقوا من اعمال عنف تحول فيه الصراع
السياسي الى صراع دموي صراع عنيف
هذا اد في تلك الفتره وما زال الى الى ما
سماه البعض بظاهره الانكشاف الاخباري ربما
اذا جاز لنا هذه التسميه
العربيه كيف تعاملت مع هذه القضايا قضيه
الربيع العربي وكما قلت بانها كانت من
اكثر القضايا المثيره للجدل اللي انقسم
فيها الناس الى قسمين اولا انا اتحفظ
كثيرا على تسميه الربيع العربي هي تسميه
مستورده احنا لو كان فرحنا في جميعنا وكان
يعني خراب عربي في وقت
نعم كان في شحن لنقل شحن كثير في الجانب
كان في عمليات تهيج كانوا بحاجه انك انت
ايضا الى صوت يكون يدعم الاستقرار هنا ترى
مهمه الاعلام ليس ناقل اخبار فقط ليس فقط
ياخذ الكاميرا الى المكان ويصور الحدث ثم
ينقلها
ولذلك نحن نقول لا موضوعي وليس حيادي
الموضوعيه انك تعطي الموضوع حقه بشك كامل
وتبعد عن نقاط طيب فيما كان هناك السياق
عمليه الاستاذ والتجييشي والتحريضي
كان الخطاب الذي تقوم في قناه العربي
وقتها ورساله توصلها انه هو دعم الاستقرار
ومواجهه هذا التحديات اليستا تدخلا وليس
فرض توجهات وانما نقلا للصوره وتوضيحا
للمخاطر التي تحدث والتقلبات وبالتالي لم
تكن مرغوبه من التيارات المتطرفه اللي
كانت تشجع يعني لو اخذنا في مصر يعني لان
المساله طالت في مصر اكثر من كذا من لم
نجد في هذا الموقف اللي كان فيه الوقت
اللي كان يشحن فيه الشارع المصري بشكل
للقيام والتمرد والفوضى وما حدثها في
الشارع المصري لم نجد من العربيه الخطاب
الذي يعيد لا الخطاب الذي كان يتكلم عن
ينقل الصور اولا ما يحدث ويدعم حق
المصريين ويحفظ يعني الاستقرار فيها ويشجع
وينقل المعلومه كانت هناك لنجد انه في
الخطاب في تلك الفتره الخطاب لم يكن
معلوماتيا كان خطابيا وتحريضيا لم يكن
هناك معلومه لم يكن هناك نقل الصوره لم
يكن هناك تطع المخاطر لم يكن هناك العين
الكاشفه فال
ليست انكشاف يمكن بعد يمكن نستخدم احيانا
مصطلحات اشد يعني هو حاله خلينا نقول
انكشاف كامل بلغه مؤدبه يعني في الجنه
لانها ما كانت المساله قائمه الاعلام
ولذلك هذه الخطوره الاعلام المؤدلج لا
يعيش طويلا لانه يخدم غرض معين فتره معينه
ثم يموت ولذلك لو نجد انا ليس لدي ارقام
لكن نجد مسار العربيه تاخذ المسار المتطور
في علاقه المشاهد فيها من ناحيه موثوقيه
وهذا جانب مهم حتى عندما اظهرت قناه الحدث
ايضا اصبح هناك حتى العربيه متنفس تواصلي
اعمق واقرب الى الناس واكثر لنقل انسانيه
فان سنه الاعلام وليس فقط يعني الماده
الخبريه الجافه ويعني من اللافت
انك التواصل الانساني مع الناس ويعني من
من ما نراه الى يعني الواقع الى منازلهم
اسال هنا من دبي استاذ عبد الله العتيبي
يعني استاذ عبد الله بعد هذا الحكي
والانكشاف ربما الاعلامي او انكشاف
السياسي كما ذكر خالد اين تتجه العربيه في
تغطياتها يعني كيف يمكن النظر الى مستقبل
العربيه في تغطياتها وفي تواجدها في
الميدان اولا باول
ما في شك عشرون عام كافيه للحكم على قناه
العربيه انها قادره دائما على التطور
وتقديم ما يجذب المشاهد وما يقنع
المشاهد بمصداقيته فكره العربيه كفكره هي
فكره
تمثل جزء من قوه السياسه الناعم هو من
القوه الناعمه للسياسه وهي تجلت على مدى
هذه العشرين عاما وتجلت ايضا في الموقف
مما كان يعرف بالربيع العربي وهو الربيع
الاصوليه التخريب وتجلت في العديد من
المواقف يعني كان هناك تحديات حقيقيه كانت
تحتاج الى
عقلانيه وواقعيه في تغطيه الاحداث الكبرى
راهنت العربيه على الموقف السياسي
العقلاني والملتزم بعيدا عن اي قوائيه نحن
نتذكر مثلا احداث القاعده نتذكر حرب 2006
وحزب الله اللبناني ونتذكر ايضا لما جاءت
الربيع العربي وبعدها ومن هنا ما دامت
القناه تعمل بالشكل الصحيح وبالرؤيه
الصحيح وبالتوجه الصحيح في اي احداث اخرى
ستمر
ستمر من نفس المصفاه ستعرض على قناه
العربيه بنفس الرؤيه وبنفس المنهج
وبالتالي يستفيد المشاهد لم يستطع المشاهد
العربي ان يستفيد من بعض القنوات في لحظه
الربيع العرب التي كانت تهيج الشارع
وتحشده وتكذب في التغطيه وتضخم لكنها
استفادت من المسائله العقلانيه والاحداث
الواقعيه والتحليل
العميق والموضوع اللي مثل هذه الاحداث
الكبرى في اقل من دقيقه انا بسالكم عن شيء
يخصنا احنا كمان هنا في الرياض تحديد
النشره الرابعه وابدا معك استاذ عبد الله
كيف شايف نشره الرابعه خاصه يمكن هي من
اهم النشرات اللي تقدم على شاشه العربيه
سريعه
ما في شك نشره الرابعه منذ بدات وتخصصها
في الشان السعودي بحكم ان المشاهد السعودي
القناه السعوديه والمشاهد السعودي
مشاهد مهم جدا لدي من الوعي والادراك
والتاثير الشيء الكبير وبالتالي كان
نشرت الرابعه قادره على ملامسه اسئله
المشاهد السعودي وعلى تقديم الاجوبه
المهمه له وعلى المشاركه في ترتيب
اولوياته وتغطيه ما يهتم به وهذا نجاح
صراحه مهم لنشره الرابعه ولاصدقائنا في
نشره الرابعه ايش رايك استاذ ياسر في نشره
الرابعه خاصه نشره الرابعه كملت هي اول
كانت هي اول نشره تقدم من هذا الاستديو
استديو استديوهاتنا في الرياض
اولا نشره الرابعه كانت هي الكبسوله
السعوديه العامه يوميا كبسوله يوميا صراحه
وطبعا تتميز بالتقرير والتقدير لكنها تعطي
ملخص كامل لما يحدث في المملكه من المستوى
السياسي الى نقل الرياضي فتعطي الجرعه
بالتاريخ جرعه
مضغوطه لكنها مشبعه بشكل كامل اتوقع يعني
اتمنى انها طبعا تزيد
عددكم ان شاء الله ويكثر لانكم محتاجين
يعني والله يعطيكم العافيه انتم يعني في
الجانب في المساله يعني صراحه ليس مديح
لكم بحكم العراق انا رايي في الجانب يعني
اعتبر من اصحاب الولاء لكن مساله مهمه ان
نجد افراح كل يوم ما شفنا يعني والجديد
صوت جديد يتغذى ولذلك انت تطور هذه النشره
ولا تصبح فقط نشره الرابعه ان شاء الله
تصبح نشرات باذن الله شكرا معنا في
الاستديو والكاتب الصحفي جاسر الجاسر ومن
دبي ايضا عبد الله ابو جاد العتي بي
الكاتب الصحفي شكرا لكما
اعتقد ان قناه العربيه ملات فراغا كبيرا
يعني من المهم
للمشاهد وخاصه في العالم العربي ان تكون
هناك منصات اخباريه
مميزه
تحمل رؤى ووجهات نظر مختلفه ويبقى الحكم
للمتلقي تكلم في العالم العربي لو لم تكن
العربيه موجوده لكان هناك اعتقد فراغ كبير
لكان هناك فراغ كبير صعب ان يملا
دبي للفقره الاقتصاديه مع نادين هاني كل
عام وانت بخير
شكرا خالد وفاطمه وكل عام وانتم وكل يعني
للعاملين بالعربيه بالف خير بطبع متابعه
سوق الاسهم السعوديه تمثل المحتوى الاكبر
لنا ضمن نشرات الاقتصاد بدايه بفقرات
تحديث الاسواق على قناه العربيه منذ
الصباح التي تعطي المستثمر معلومات موجزه
حول ابرز ما يحرك الاسواق خلال اليوم سواء
عالميا او محليا وايضا اهم ما تتراقبه
الاسواق من بيانات واجتماعات مهمه وهو ما
حارسنا عليهم منذ انطلاق الاسواق العربيه
تقديم كل ما يهم المستثمر بشكل خاص نبض
السوق الاسواق العربيه غداء عمل وجرس
الاغلاق برامج اصبحت مرجعا للاعلام
الاقتصادي منذ ان انطلقت عام 2005 بفريقها
المتخصص بخبره صحفيه واعلاميه واقتصاديه
وماليه فريق واكبا دون ملل اهم وابرز
الاخبار والاحداث والمتغيرات التي حركت
جوانب الاقتصاد وقادت قطاعات المال
والاعمال محليا في منطقه الخليج وفي
مقدمتها السوق السعوديه وعربيا وعالميا
على مدار السنوات الماضيه وحتى الان وهو
ما سنواصل الالتزام به اليوم وغدا سوق
الاسهم السعوديه كان لها نصيب الاسد من
تغطيتنا منذ البدايه
2006 عام القمه والقاع العام الذي تغيرت
بعده اليه عمل سوق الاسهم والسوق الماليه
السعوديه ليفتح المجال امام تطوير
التشريعات والقوانين واللوائح المنظمه
للسوق من حيث التداول وتشديد المراقبه
وفرض الغرامات على المخالفين 2006 لا ينسى
ما حدا لتغيير منظومه العمل في السوق
لتعزز مكانه تداول كاهم واكبر سوق عربي
بقيمه سوقيه تتجاوز التريليون و700 مليار
دولار حاليا فما الذي حدث في 2006 هو عام
لن ننساه كان العامل اكثر تقلبا وتاثيرا
بدءا من القمه التي بلغها اتعسي في 25
فبراير فوق مستوى العشرين الف وستمائه
نقطه واستقيم التداولات يوميه كان تجاوزت
ال 50 مليار ريال ثم جاءت التقلبات
الشديده والهبوط المتواصل باكثر من الف
نقطه يوميه كانت ايام صعبه هو ما بدا في
صباح 26 فبراير ومتابعه من تغييرات
وقرارات لاحقه غيرت توجهات سوق الماليه
بشكل عام حتى يومنا هذا نذكر هنا بان مؤشر
تاسي وصل الى ادنى مستوى له في مارس 2009
حيث سجل نحو 4000 نقطه
[تصفيق]
هذه مستويات قياسيه جديده نراها على سوق
الاسهم السعوديه ويبدو اننا نقترب جدا من
حاجز 21 الف نقطه اليوم ارتفاع ب 340 نقاط
او ما يعادل واحد ونصف في المئه على مؤشر
سوق الاسهم السعوديه الذي يقف الان عند
20,000
نقطه اليوم سوق الاسهم السعوديه تسجل
تراجعات حاده الي يبدو انه عند الاغلاق
مؤشر السوق يخسر اكثر من ثلاثه في المئه
عدد كبير من الشركات تغلق على انخفاض
بالحد الاقصى المسموح به قيمه للتداول لم
تتجاوز 7 مليار بينما تعودنا انها تتجاوز
45 مليار او تقريبا مليار اربعين مليار
خلال الفتره الماضيه هل يدلك على ان هناك
عدم قناعه كثيره في قضيه المضاربه
وبالتالي اتضحت المساله انه من الغير
منطقي هذه الاسعار الكثير من الشركات
وبالتالي الجميع رغبه التخلص من هذه
الشركات
[موسيقى]
غير انه شكلي كان مختلف تماما عم نحكي عن
17 سنه لورا ولكن كانت اياما صعبه بالفعل
خاصه لانه بحينها كان جميع السعوديين
لديهم اسهم وبالتالي كانت ظاهره شراء
افراد وبالتالي عند الوصول الى القمه ومن
ثم النزول الصعب الذي حدث بالسوق فقد
الكثير جنى عمرهم وبالتالي كانت ايام صعبه
ومليئه بالالم لانه عم نتحدث عن خساره عدد
كبير من الناس لجنى العمر بالتالي من هنا
بدات الحاجه
للتشريعات التي لحقت بعد ذلك بالطبع كان
لنشرات قسم الاقتصاد في العربيه الحضور
والتواجد الاكثر بين اوساط المستثمرين
والمهتمين باسواق المال من السعوديين
لمتابعه حزم التغييرات التي عاقبت هبوط
سوق الاسهم والتي كانت بوتيره شبه يوميه
كان لنا لقاءات حصريه مع المسؤولين
السعوديين في تصريحات كان يتراقبها
الكثيرون لحظه بلحظه
[موسيقى]
ومنذ تاسيس الهيئه عمل جماس السحيمي
الرئيس السابق لهيئه السوق الماليه على
الارتقاء بنوعيه التداولات في السوق
السعوديه وهو الدور الذي تعاهد الرئيس
الجديد الدكتور عبد الرحمن التويجري
بالعمل على تصويره في المرحله المقبله
نتراجع الكبير في اسعار الاسهم
لتاثيره المباشر على ملايين المواطنين ولا
يتلائم مع الوضع الاقتصادي العامه الذي
تعيشه بلادنا من ازدهار الاقتصادي والتي
تتمتع فيه بمعدلاته نمو عاليه
في ميزانيه الحكومه وميزان المدفوعات ولا
يوجد تضخم
[موسيقى]
على كلن يعني هذا التغيير اللي حدث بحينها
كان الناس يحتاجون الى رؤيه تغيير يحتاجون
الى رؤيه اخذ المسؤولين بجديه الخساره
الضخمه التي حصلت في السوق السعوديه منذ
ذلك الحين بظن تاخذ القرار انه يتحول
السوق الى مؤسساتي ادخال المؤسسات المحليه
والعالميه لحتى يصير استثمار الافراد يشكل
نسبه اقل من السوق ولا يعود سوق متقلب على
هوى استثمارات الافراد وليس المؤسسات فاذا
التحول الاكبر نحو العالميه بدا فعليا من
بعد سلسله خطوات ولكن بيونيو 2015 مع
السماح للمستثمرين الاجانب المؤهلين
بالدخول في السوق الماليه السعوديه بعد ان
تم تحديث قواعد وشروط استثمار الاجانب
مرتين خلال عامي 2016 و2018 كما كانت ابرز
ثمار منظومه حزم الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والماليه بعد اعوام قليله من اطلاق رؤيه
المملكه 2030 هي ترقيه سوق الاسهم
السعوديه الى مصاف الاسواق الناشئه في عام
2019 من قبل اكبر ثلاث شركات عالميه
للمؤشرات ام السي اي فوت راسل واسم بيدا
جونس
[موسيقى]
سوق الاسهم السعوديه عن كثب وذلك لانه بدا
من اليوم يستطيع المستثمر الاجنبي شراء
المباشر في سوق عبر
ترخيص يحصل عليه كاكيو اف اي [__] فايف
[موسيقى]
نادين بالفعل يعني التقارير ايجابيه جدا
حول انعكاس فتح السوق السعوديه على اسواق
المنطقه بشكل عام وتحديدا اسواق الامارات
[موسيقى]
صعب واحد يشوف حاله من سنوات فريق الاسواق
العربيه تواجد بشكل بارز اثناء التحضيرات
الاوليه وحتى الادراج الاكبر في السوق
السعوديه حيث شهد ديسمبر من عام 2019
المحطه الاهم الاكبر ظهورا في عناوين
الاخبار الاقتصاديه محليا وعالميا هي طرح
ارامكو الذي جمع سته وتسعين مليار ريال او
25 مليار دولار ليكون في حينها اكبر
اكتتاب عام في تاريخ اسواق الاسهم
العالميه ومع اكتتاب ارامكو اصبحت سوق
الاسهم السعوديه في ذلك الحين تاسع اكبر
بورصه في العالم بقيمه سوقيه لشركات
المدرجه تصل الى تريليونين و300 مليار
دولار بعد طول انتظار تستقبل سوق الاسهم
السعوديه اليوم سهم ارامكو بعد انتهاء
الاكتتاب العام الاولي الاكبر في العالم
بقيمه 25 مليارا و600 مليون دولار بطلبات
شراء فاقد الاسهم المعروضه
بما يقارب خمسه اضعاف
ادراج اسهم ارامكو تحت مظله
[موسيقى]
المؤشر
وعلى الرغم من الظروف المفاجئه والصعبه
التي فرضتها ازمه تفشي كورونا بالاعوام
الثلاثه الماضيه الا ان سوق السعوديه وصلت
التطوير والتحديات ليتم الاعلان عن ادراج
وتداول اسهم شركه مجموعه تداول السعوديه
القابضه تم ادراجها بالسوق الرئيسيه
اعتبارا من الثامن من ديسمبر 2021 وذلك
بعد تحولها الى شركه قابضه باسم مجموعه
تداول السعوديه قباله طرح العام الاولي
ياتي الطرح كتويج لنشاط الطروحات العامه
الاوليه ليزداد عمق السوق مع تنوع
المنتجات والادوات الاستثماريه المدرجه
فيها بعدد يتجاوز 220 شركه حاليا ماذا
تغير في الهيكل الجديد شركه السوق الماليه
تداول تحولت الى شركه قابضه باسم مجموعه
تداول السعوديه وتحت مظلتها اربع شركات هي
تداول كسوق للاوراق الماليه وشركه مركز
مقاصه الاوراق الماليه مقص وشركه مركز ايد
اوراق الماليه ايداع وشركه موفنت الجديده
والمتخصصه في الخدمات والحلول التقنيه
القائمه على الابتكار وبدا اليوم ادراج
وتداول سهم شركه مجموعه تداول السعوديه
القابضه في السوق الرئيسيه بعد ان تم
الاكتتاب بالاسهم بسعر 105
قد طرحت 36 مليون سهم تمثل 30% من
راسمالها للاكتتاب العام تم تخصيص 70%
منها للشركات و30% للافراد
التغطيه او الاسواق العربيه بشكل لتعرفونه
الان لم يبدا مع انطلاقه العربيه
بالتالي لا نستطيع اختصار مسيره 18 عاما
من التغطيه لاسواق المنطقه وخاصه سوق
الاسهم السعوديه واخبار المنطقه ببضع
الدقائق هذه كانت بعض المحطات لكن ربما
الانجاز الاكبر هو انه اعتاد الناس على
متابعه الاخبار الاقتصاديه معنا اصبحت
ضروره ان يتابعوننا ويعلمون بكل ما يدور
من اخبار اقتصاديه في المنطقه لانها
بالفعل تمس بحياتهم اليوميه كون ايضا دول
الخليج هي مقر لاستثمارات ضخمه فاذا
العبره لا نستطيع ان نختصرها بالماضي
وبهذه الفقره بل بالحاضر والمستقبل نعطكم
بان نبقى السباقين فيه بتغطيه سوق الاسهم
السعوديه وغيرها من الاسواق والاخبار
الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
عملت العربيه طوال سنوات على 20 على تعزيز
فكره الاعتدال ونبذ الافكار المتطرفه عبر
الكثير من البرامج من ابرزها البرنامج
صناعه الموت فضلا عن الكثير من الافلام
الوثائقيه احدث اصدارات العربيه في هذا
الصدد كان بودكاست جمعت الذي تقدمه
الزميلة هدى الصالح
تفضلي فاطمه في الاستوديو طبعا الكاتبه
الصحفيه الزميله هدى الصالح اهلا بك معنا
هدى يعني
سنوات كثيره لها خبره في هذا المجال
الاسلاميه 19 سنه تحديدا وانت تتعاملي
معاهم تبحثي عنهم تكتبي عنهم وتقراي عنهم
هدى يعني قولي لنا ربما ابرز المحطات التي
مررت بها مع العربيه في تغطياتك لهذه
الجماعات الاسلاميه طبعا كانت ابرز محطه
هي بدايه ما عرف بالربيع العربي لكن انا
اعتقد المسمى الحقيقي او الادق موسم
الحصاد للجماعات الراديكاليه المسلحه كما
اطلق عليه ايمن الظواهري واسامه بن لادن
واعتبروه كذلك وهو بالفعل كان يعني زمن
نهضه وصحوه جديده للجماعات المسلحه خلال
العشر سنوات
فبدايه العمل مع العربيه كان من هذا
التاريخ
وحاولت اني اغطي مع كافه التي المحسوبه في
يعني في داخل التيار الصحوي سواء السروريه
سواء الاصوليه الجهاديه السلفيه الجهاديه
او التيارات الاخرى في مثلا في افغانستان
في باكستان وغيرها فنحاول انه نقرا شو
المفارقات اللي كانت في ديك الفتره وايضا
من الشق السياسي لهذه الجماعات وهي المضخه
النظريه لهذه الجماعات المسلحه طب في
تغطياتك هذه تحديدا هدى يعني ماذا قدمت
العربيه لك من تسهيلات ربما ومن
خلينا نقول لاجل انك تقدري تغطيها بشكل
ادق وافضل اشكرك على هذا السؤال
تفضلي انا اشكرك صراحه على هذا السؤال لان
هذه شهاده يعني واجب ذكرها ان الاستاذ
الاستاذ ممدوح المهيني كان هو اللي في
البدايه اللي طلب مني فقط ان يعني اعتكف
على هذه المواضيع يعني انه قليل جدا ما
تلاقي في في مجالنا بالذات في المجتمعاتنا
العربيه او في الاعلام العربي ان هناك من
يركز على او يفهم ويعني يقيم مهمه الصحافه
المتخصصه فكان للسيد ممدوح معتني جدا في
هذا الاطار فكل صحفي كان يعني يضع في
موقعه
وما يجيده في هذا المجال فطلب يعني
وشجاني على ان اعتكف على هذه المواد ولا
اخرج عنها فكانت عندي مساحه وقت لقراءه
ومتابعه سواء الكتب
والاصداراتهم ومطبوعاتهم حساباتهم في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في تيليجرام في
تويتر
فتحتاجي للتفرغ التام حتى تراقبي كل شيء
في هذا يعني ما هو سهل تكوني متخصصه فقط
بانك تتابعي الاخبار او تتابع احداث لا
متخصص لابد ان تقرا يعني تحاول قدر
الامكان ان تقرا معظم ما يخرجون من
اصدارات حتى تقيمها وتقارنها ما بين الامس
واليوم وش التطور لحدث لها
هدى صالح الكاتب الصحفي شكرا لك شكرا شكرا
لم يجبان الخليجيه من عن شاشه العربيه
التي تابعت اهم وابرز احداث الخليج طوال
عقدين من الزمن من السياسه الى القضايا
الاجتماعيه وليس انتهاء بالثقافه والرياضه
نتابع
[تصفيق]
تجد اليوم في الامارات مرحله التصويت
النهائيه لانتخابات المجلس الوطني
الاتحاديه الاعلان عن الاسامي ستكون في
العاصمه ابوظبي في المركز الرئيسي
قد سجلت السلطات العمانيه سبعه وفيات
جديده بسبب اعصار الشاهين
[موسيقى]
العالقين الاسراع في اصلاح البنيه التحتيه
والوقائع اعصار شاهين الذي ضرب عمان
[تصفيق]
كيف ترى سلطنه عمان مشهد الدول او الازمات
في المنطقه هناك ازمات صعبه معقده وشائكه
[تصفيق]
هذا المسجد يمتد عمره لاكثر من
1400 عام
سنكون معكم من العلا على الهواء مباشره
الذي سيتم توقيعه في هذه القمه المباركه
البدايه من الكويت الواقعه في اقصى جمال
الخليفه العربي
معنا من الجبيل فضل البوعينين عضو مجلس
الشورى استاد تفضل حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه ومبروك علينا وعليك
العربيه وخليني ابدا معك انت متابع
للعربيه بالتاكيد وضحت ضيوفها البارزين
ومتخصصين ودائما تصحبنا في الكثير من
القضايا التي تهم المواطن الخليجي ما
نصيبه برايك يعني او نصيب الشان الخليجي
الى اي مدى وصل في قناه العربيه براي فضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في خالد انا لم
اسمع السؤال ولكن ابدا اولا
بتهنئه العربيه بعمل عشرين عشرين عاما من
التميز
والموضوعيه والنزاهه والانتشار وايضا على
هذه الجهود الاعلاميه خاصه في الاعلام
الاقتصادي الذي اثرت تاثيرا كبيرا في
المجتمع العربي واصبح له صدا كبيرا خاصه
وان العربيه تنحى منحه لتعزيز التنميه
والاستقرار وتقديم الخبر بما يساعد على
نشر هذه الثقافه ثقافه البناء والتنميه
والاستقرار وهذا امر كنا في امس الحاجه له
في الفضاء الاعلامي شكرا للعربيه ولجميع
العاملين فيه على كل ما قدموا من
جهود في عام الماضيه ان شاء الله تسمعني
الان الان اسمعك كنت اسال عن نصيب المشاهد
الخليجي من قناه العربيه من برامجها من
الاخبار التي تقدمها التحليلات وغيرها
بدانا نصيب الاسد خاصه وان العربيه اصبحت
تبث نشرات اخ
باريه
في الدول
وبالتالي اصبح هناك توجيه مباشر لتغطيه
شامله لاخبار هذه الدول وبالتالي نرى
اليوم انتشار كبير
العربيه نرى ايضا ارتفاع كبير في عدد
المشاهدات ليس من خلال القناه وبسها ولكن
حتى من
المنصات الاخرى الاعلاميه الاخرى منصات
الاجتماع التواصل الاجتماعي وهذا له
تاثير في جانبين اساسيين حقيقي
ين سيد فضل يعني تغطيتها وتواجدها على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ومواكبه التطورات
في التغطيات ونقل الخبر الى المشاهد كيف
ترى تجربه العربيه في اثراء المشاهد
الخليجي وفي نقل مواضيعه وقضاياه
الدول الخليجيه على وجه الخصوص الدول
العربيه
وعندما تربط بين منصات موجه عن طريق
القناه مباشره والمنصات المتخصصه على
الوسائط الاجتماعيه اضافه الى موقعها
الاخباري ايضا على الانترنت فبالتالي هي
تصل الى كل منزل وكل مشاهد عربي وما يهمني
في هذا الجانب حقيقه انها تلامس الايجابي
في المشاهد العربي وتنميه وايضا حمله على
التفاعل الايجابي مع كل ما يهم بتنميه
المجتمع العربي ان كان اقتصاديا سياسيا او
ثقافيا او امنيا نعم
مساله كثيره سريعه اذا حاولنا ابرز حذف
تابعته على قناه العربيه
اولا بما ذكرته المقدمه الاخ مدين وهي
انهيار السوق الاسمر اعتقد ان ذلك كان من
اكثر المشاهد الى من انا اتكلم بجانب
الاقتصادي فقط واما الجانب المفرح حقيقه
نقل العربيه
مباشر
لتصريحات سمولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان واطلاق رؤيه المملكه 2030 الرؤيه
المباركه التي اثرت في التي التي احدثت
تحول الاقتصاديا كبيرا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ثم ادراج ارامكو ثم المشروعات
الك
برى عن طريق سمو ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن القنديه البحر الاحمر الدرعيه
بوابه الدرعيه مؤخرا المربع الجديد كل هذه
الاحداث الاقتصاديه كانت مهمه بالنسبه فقط
ولكن للمجتمع السعودي ولجميع الدول
الباحثه
الاقتصادي هذا من اهم الاحداث التي حقيقه
شهدتها في العربي ولكن جميع الاحداث التي
تنقلها العربيه مهمه لكل مشاهد عربي اختم
اذا كان لي اقل من دقيقه اذا سمحتي
المجلس الشورى السعودي
نعتذر منك نختم هذه الساعه مشاهدينا لكن
تغطيتنا مستمره لعيد العربيه العشرين
زميلان احمد الهادي نهايه الاحمري سيكون
معكم على
راس الساعه شكرا لكم والى اللقاء يعطيك
العافيه